So you see that when we compare samples, we're simply extending the idea of the
t test. We can compare samples to each other by seeing how far each sample mean
is from the mean of means, or the grand mean, and this is between group
variability. But we also want to look at the variability of each sample, and
that's within group variability. Because this impacts whether or not the
samples are significantly different. Since we're analyzing variabilities, this
process is called analysis of variance, shortened to ANOVA. ANOVA can compare
as many means as we want with just one test. We say one way ANOVA when we have
one independent variable sometimes called a factor. In this course we'll only
work with one way ANOVA.